now we know that you're only watching
this video because Elan musk was in the
title but we're not alone here the
Internet is saturated with Elon Musk his
name and likeness tried-and-true
clickbait here's a meme asking the
internet to stop with all the Elon Musk
memes talk about meta so what is it
about Elon Musk that seems to have
captivated the entire Internet we
decided to ask Bloomberg reporter Ashley
Vance who actually wrote the book on
Elon
I think after Steve Jobs died there was
this hunt to see who was the next big
figure people were gonna latch on to and
Elon emerged as the cult-like figure
that really stood out building Rockets
electric cars nobody else does things
like this he's a force in society that's
like a cross-pollination of Thomas
Edison and Tony Stark over time he's
just come to embody this Tony Stark like
figure more and more yeah I can fly he
is probably the biggest risk taker on
the planet every single time one of his
companies does well he seems to just go
all-in again and take another even
bigger risk and he seems to enjoy living
on the edge at all times you know Elon
ultimately is this huge brand even more
so than his company's
[Music]
musk got his business and physics degree
from UPenn and he pursued a ph.d program
at Stanford for a short time but changed
course to pursue business opportunities
with his brother Kimball his first big
payday came from a company they launched
together called zip to zip to began as a
sort of online Yellow Pages offering
local businesses a way to launch a
webpage on their platform but it quickly
went national as a way for newspapers to
harness the power of the burgeoning
internet after securing partnerships
with 160 publications across the country
compact computer took an interest in
incorporating zip to software into their
Alta Vista search engine and acquired
them for 370 million dollars in 1999
Elan received 22 million dollars from
the sale musk then spent about half of
his new fortune to create one of the
world's first online baking systems
called XCOM XCOM quickly merged with a
competing financial software company
founded by none other than Peter Thiel
called con Finity con Finity eventually
morphed into PayPal with musk its
biggest shareholder and CEO PayPal was
sort of a disaster-free Elan he ran the
company for a few months - about a year
and then there was this massive COO
co-founders Peter Thiel David sacks met
one night while Elon was away on
vacation and threw him out of the
company more or less but Elon remained a
majority shareholder which was ideal
when PayPal was bought out by eBay for
1.4 billion dollars Elon personally made
around 170 million dollars from that now
if most people were to receive that kind
of money at the age of 31 they would
likely check out for a bit
buy an island and a boat listen to the
ocean breeze for the rest of your life
but not Elon
he ends up putting about a hundred
million in the spacex 70 million into
tesla and then 30 million in the solar
city you're more or less just literally
lighting your money on fire and that's
exactly what he did
both SpaceX and Tesla remains a
notorious money pits for over a decade
the Dow off more than 500 points this is
what financial Armageddon looks like in
2008 the whole economy is tanking while
he's trying to raise money for these
companies that he's blown through his
whole fortune rockets are just extremely
difficult he has to take loans from
friends
Tesla stock voted by Wall Street as the
least likely to succeed at the same time
he's just had a divorce it was the
darkest time in his life without
question musk kept his sights high
played the long game and weathered the
storm it's one of the great sort of
escape acts in business histories that
he actually manages to keep both
companies alive to get a rocket to space
and to get the Tesla Roadster out the
door
today musk has a 54 percent stake in
SpaceX which is valued at thirty three
billion dollars and has become the
number one private space exploration
company in the world
Tesla's profitability has remained
spotty over the years but in 2019 they
posted a quarterly profit of a hundred
forty three million dollars a few years
ago people were laughing at you now not
so much I mean okay
today Elon Musk's total net worth is at
around twenty three point six billion
dollars and alongside SpaceX and Tesla
musk has launched multiple future facing
side projects like the boring company
open AI and neural link all of which are
inspired by a passion for making science
fiction concepts a reality but
ultimately Elon has his sights set on
redder pastures we should really be
setting the goal as the creation of a
self-sustaining civilization on Mars
when SpaceX first started the idea was
to make rockets that were just much
cheaper than the competition but always
lurking in the back of his mind the real
true goal of the company was to make a
rocket that could get to Mars and start
a human colony
over the years it's oddly become a lot
more realistic and they're already
building a spaceship that he actually
thinks will get to Mars he wants
intellect risk-taking in subsequent
successes against all odds have come to
inspire a generation to do the
impossible and with this the cult of
Elon has grown exponentially but with
great power comes great responsibility
not to mention a twitter account
somewhere along the way he decided to
also just let the kind of bling part of
himself come out sand and pick fights
and and say really outlandish things and
it's done nothing but get him in trouble
in 2018 the sec find Elon twenty million
dollars for floating the idea of taking
Tesla private but that didn't stop him
from tweeting that Tesla was going
bankrupt as an April Fool's joke but
Elon
that's not funny when people are nervous
I mean it's April Fool's cool [ __ ] like
lighten up okay in July of 2018
Elon called Vernon Unsworth a diver
risking his life to save the children's
thai soccer team from the caves a pedo
guy Tesla shares fell 4% and he was
slapped with a defamation lawsuit he
defeated the lawsuit but not without
some bad PR Burnham went toe-to-toe with
a billionaire blood bully then of course
he smoked pot on the Joe Rogan show
Tesla's stock dropped 8% that day and
wound up putting a six point eight
billion dollar NASA contract with SpaceX
in jeopardy I think he's putting a dent
in a lot of the goodwill that he had
built up and and so he's become a much
more divisive figure in these days he
loves gonna be better behaved moving
forward he hasn't given us a lot of
indications of that it seems to be going
the opposite way his behavior seems more
erratic
ever he now really relishes being in the
spotlight and seems to want to try to
one-up himself all the time just to keep
this thing going maybe it's like that
old saying you can't make an omelet
without breaking a few eggs and if must
mid life remains as unpredictable and
tumultuous as as early career then we
should expect a lot more broken eggs
from here to Mars
you